- [Man] Ah, yes the Pee tape.
- Pee tape.
- It's possible.
- Jim it's possible.
And it's possible martians,
martians, martians
we're in that room peeing
on the prostitutes too.
- [Man] That sick liberal
fantasy I can't stop,
I mean they can't stop thinking about.
- I went to Russia on business.
I love it there and I
especially love the prostitutes.
I'm Donald, do you like
high powered business men?
I do.
Good.
I want you to call one of
your prostitute friends.
Tell her to bring over a
bunch of bottles of water.
I want to fill your bladders.
Obama stayed here once.
I want to use the toilet Obama used.
No you'll pee on the bed.
The bed where Obama slept.
I hate Obama so much.
(unzipping)
Okay here comes the pee.
(liquid pouring)
Good God that's a lot of pee.
What's that coming out of the shadows?
(yells) It's aliens.
Get out of here you aliens.
Wait.
Unless you also want to pee
on the bed where Obama slept.
Oh my God they're peeing on us.
The aliens are peeing on you
and you're peeing on the bed
good God that's a lot of pee.
Someone's been recording this whole thing.
I'm still peeing.
I hope no one tries to
blackmail me with this.
Yeah, that's exactly how it all went down.
Sick liberals.
(rock music)